مشاهدينا نتابع هذه الصور المباشره من
هاتاي التركيه حيث رافقت كاميرا العربيه
اليوم عمليه انقاذ ثلاثه اشخاص بينهم طفل
من تحت الانقاض فيها تركيا مراسل العربيه
مشاهدينا اكد ان الشخصين البالغين الذين
تم انقاذهما هما بصحه جيده اما الطفل ففي
حاله صحيه سيئه وقد تم نقلكم جميعا الى
المستشفى لتلقي العلاج عمليه الانقاذ
مشاهدينا جرت بعد قرابه ثلاثمائه ساعه على
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا فجر
السادس من فبراير الماضي
ارتفعت مشاهدينا حصيله القتلى في البلدين
الى خمسه
ووزير الداخليه التركي كان ايضا اعلن
ارتفاع عدد الضحايا في بلاده الى
39,672 شخصا الوزير اضاف ايضا مشاهدينا ان
حوالي 82 الف مبنى انهار بشكل كامل او
تضرر بشده نتيجه الزلزال فيما فاق عدد
المصابين المئه وخمسه الاف مصاب حتى
اللحظه اذا مازلنا معكم مشاهدينا في
متابعه هذه الصور المباشره منها التركيه
حيث تستمر عمليات الانقاذ وانتشال الجثث
وفي هذا المبنى الذي كان مكونا من اربعه
او من خمسه طوابق وكان تم انتشال الجثث
والناجين ايضا من الذين كانوا يسكنون في
الطابق الرابع بحسب ما افاده مراسل
العربيه في نشاط سابقه